Доброго ранку шановні товариство хоча
важко наші ранки називати добрими і цей
не виявився винятком тому що в твоєму
мед коли ми маємо Шалені розкрадання на
рівні Міністерства оборони тих коштів
які мають іти в нас потреби ЗСУ в той
час коли під покровом військових
адміністрацій і правоохоронних органів
ми маємо масове розкрадання гуманітарки
і ніхто не знає куди Що Пішло і куди що
зникло в той час коли на стратегічні
посади призначаються не те що про
Московський але відверто ригірські
персоналії які роками долучалися до
знищення України
Влада знайшла цапа відбувається і на
сьогоднішній момент це не виявився
депутат від європейської солідарності
Сергій Алексеєв правник якого нібито
звинувачують у шахрайстві за те що він
отримав кошти від клієнта фірми в якій
він має частку щоб передати ці кошти
керівнику фірми які на той час не зміг
бути присутнім бо в нього померла
близька людина і в цей момент
Виявляється що він найбільший злочинець
у нашій державі
ви мені скажете давайте Хай розберуться
за законом щоби все було правильно але
тепер розкажіть мені будь ласка А де
закон в якому місці коли до Сергія
вриваються пів першої ночі з обшуками А
де його 81-літньої матері пів четвертої
ночі До напівсмерті лякаючи літню жінку
Скажіть мені будь ласка А де закон коли
приходять правоохоронці без будь-якого
взагалі документу який санкціонує обшук
чи інші слідчі дії взагалі без
документів мені писали А чому він
впустив їх до хати а ви дуже попрете
проти людей з автоматами А скажіть мені
де закон коли дбр призначає суд у Львові
хоча це мав би бути Шевченківський
районний суд міста Києва але давайте
згадаємо що ж таке дбр
- це структура яка останні кілька років
займалася репресіями Військових
Ветеранів волонтерів тепер займалися
моєю з Марусею справою за те щоб
потерпілий злякався слів що холера на
передовій стріляють за відведені війська
Золотому там де полягло після
повномасштабного Московського вторгнення
тисячі українських воїнів а давайте
згадаємо що таке дбр це структура яка
звалила з Києва в першій хвилині
повномасштабного вторгнення і до сих пір
боїться повертатися до Києва давайте
згадаємо що таке дбр і хто його керує а
керує дбр заступник глави офісу
президента Олег Татаров публічник
Януковича який займався в репресієм
проти євромайданівців
автомайданівців зокрема Тетяни чорнову
який вважає Майдан Революції гідності
масовими заворушеннями з
використанням сили
ось такий закон Сьогодні у нашій державі
тому товариство Я дуже попросила щоб
сьогодні і наступні дні місяці Ми дуже
святкували за роками махінаторів тому що
сьогодні вас цією фейковою підставною
справою відволікають від реального стану
справ у нашій державі тому що сьогодні
марафони будуть розносити тільки брехні
не дає чим можливості нікому з опозиції
розказати А що ж насправді відбувається
щоби люди мали можливість скласти свою
думку давайте також поговоримо про закон
коли слугам народи які вбивають людей в
авто аваріях дають можливість гуляти
спокійно і по Україні їздити за кордон і
сидіти в Верховній раді коли слугам які
тіхонько тікають в ліс підкупляють
поліцейських які роблять махінації на
мільйони спокійно дають можливість
виїхати за кордон по волонтерській
складовій ось Це сьогодні так званий
закон а нам сьогодні треба в цих реаліях
вистояти і треба в цих реаліях
допомагати ЗСУ перемагати Московського
ворога а далі братися за наведення
порядку у власній Українській державі